a new whiskey distillery with a special
place in American history will open its
doors to the public in Tennessee in
September the whiskey uncle nearest
honors the first known african-american
master distiller in the country we first
brought you the lost story of nearest
green also known as Uncle nearest about
two years ago
he's the slave who taught Jack Daniel
how to make whiskey and now that the
secrets out near a screen is getting a
shot at cementing his own legacy this is
about Tennessee history best-selling
author Fon Weaver is an unlikely force
in Tennessee whiskey country just two
weeks ago these are all horse stalls in
less than three years she's launched
uncle nearest and raised about 20
million dollars to take over the
whiskey's production and turned this
horse farm into a distillery
you went from reading a story in the
International Times to becoming the
first female the first of color person
to run a major whiskey or spirit brand
yeah overall period it's her way of
honoring the man known to some as the
godfather of Tennessee whiskey if you
want to appreciate jazz better know who
Louis Armstrong was and if you want to
appreciate American whiskey you should
know who Nathan nearest Greene was
Jeffrey Wright from HBO's Westworld
feels so passionately about preserving
Greene story nears Green was a slave
here but he made a short film to honor
him in the late 1850s a farm owners
Slade known as nearest Greene started
working with a young orphan named Jack
Daniel we just need to know stories like
this because it it smashes the lives
there is no known photograph of nearest
Greene but this is his son George
sitting right next to Jack Daniel a
black man and a white man sitting side
by side at a deeply divided time in the
deep American South you have
is great iconic American brand and this
thing that is representative something
that sits in our soul that's created by
the coming together of two families an
unlikely partnership that partnership
was an open secret in Lynchburg
Tennessee it's kind of a same family
William Hussey jr. is a member of the
Tennessee Squires a Jack Daniels fan
club of sorts you believe in this brand
so much you've like literally inked it
on your skin yes and this one here is
the Jack Daniels like the barrel house
and different barrels and this is my
newest uncle nearest which is a piece of
Jack Daniels history this has changed
the story that folks in these parts had
been living with most of their lives how
are they dealing with this well I would
say about 95 percent has understood and
it was set to death and I think there's
still the 5% of old southern boys who
could care less would like to keep
everything hidden he's become an
unlikely ambassador for uncle nearest
another steward of the story as author
Fon Weaver likes to say every single
time you take that sip you should be
telling the story of nearest that's how
we make sure that his legacy is not only
seen minted but it continues on beyond
us to the next generation I wish my
grandmother could see this I do I am
near screens great-great granddaughter
Victoria Edie Butler says the idea to
make a whiskey burying her ancestors
name came first from a member of Jack
Daniels family and then from her own
farm was like what can we do to keep
near screens legacy alive and one family
member said but his name on a bottle
three of nearest Greene's descendants
still work at the Jack Daniel's
distillery
they were solidly behind you in this
discovery mode of who uncle nearest was
you're their competition now aren't you
do not consider myself competition
whatsoever when we go out into the
marketplace we are selling uncle nearest
but we are talking about Jack in a way
that makes you want to drink Jack Daniel
as well an unlikely friendship an iconic
American brand and now a legacy that can
never be forgotten what happens when
everything we know about something
changes this is a story that unifies us
and I think we so desperately need that
now we for ever will be in this thing
together and that's the story of Nathan
near screen uncle nearest and Jack
Daniel is currently in 48 states a
hundred and forty eight countries as she
said the fastest-growing independent
American spirit and a lot of the
proceeds go into a foundation the
mission of which is to make sure that
every descendant gets a college
education ten so far or through college
it's amazing what they're doing very
impressive and another brand of whiskey
for me to try those samples here at the
table did you try it I did you can go to
my Instagram page and check out my react
I'm going to your office next we'll look
at what mattered this week we'll be
right back